an act of war horrific scenes on the
streets of Paris as scores were killed
hundreds injured EU defense ministers
backed French president Francois
Hollande call to trigger Article 42 7 of
the EU treaty taking the Union into
uncharted territory the mutual defense
close calls on countries to come to the
aid of a member state that is the victim
of armed aggression on his territory see
in volunteer amber I'm she died she
owned again no pass some time ago that
tactile released its Erik lamela's
solidarity day mom do you know I think
it's bizarre that he's gone for 42.7
first of all naturally all allies would
rally to the assistance of France of
this particular moment I have heard it
suggested that this by calling on 42.7
it would be a catalyst for more
development of the used common security
and depend upon see France is now
struggling to balance operations in
Africa the Sahel and Syria with a now
heightened security situation at home
all options are on the table including
collective airstrikes on Isis
strongholds in Syria but will cutting
the head of a so-called Islamic state be
enough to stop further attacks on EU
soil yes sir colonel yeah yeah yeahs to
that fizzle that shonky drafted Congo
she quickly Salvador said you walk have
I'm your song so how will the EU respond
and what will each member state be
willing to contribute good article 42-7
be the basis for future collective
action
I